how does a cartel
take power
how does he gain control of this local
area that you mentioned and then grow
get take control of a region and how
does it do so in this dynamic
relationship between
um
politicians and the military and the
police force it's a thing that happens
over time
there has always been a big effort even
when I was in uh to buy or own certain
members of the police force even weren't
going through training some people get
pulled out during training because they
were found out to have some sort of
parent or sibling that was a cartel
member or they uh their FBI background
check came back negative you know when
they were already in the training
program
um so I I think part of it is
first off they take advantage of the
fact that Mexico is a young country it's
a country of young people
um we have a a big group of young people
that have little to no opportunities to
come up
uh when I was in when I went to take
that career path a lot of my friends
took the other option you know they they
went to work for some of these criminal
groups
um so they have this going for them they
basically have a lot of bodies to to to
hire cheaply and leverage in terms of uh
forcing those bodies to do whatever is
needed because the alternative for those
people is is nothing there's no options
yeah so you have a kid somewhere who is
working on a field you know or you have
a kid like me that was out of the job
out of school and the only options for
me was uh this bad in the newspaper
which seemed like a long shot or going
with uh some of my friends that had cars
now and we're hanging out all night at
these uh bars and some of them had you
know just
Draco AK-47 uh pistols in their cars and
it would look cool you know
so there is a trajectory there's many
trajectories possible in your life where
you could have been still operating in a
uh criminal organization in Mexico yeah
I mean it's there's not a lot of options
you know do you think you'd be good at
it
I I don't know I mean I'm pretty good at
what I do now which is teaching people
how to detect it and kind of fight
against it you know so I think uh I have
a sense that that
the skills transfer pretty well that's
also the dark side of this whole thing a
lot of the people that I used to work
with you know I I know things and I have
them training I had some specialized
training and I I currently do I've done
you know presentations for the Secret
Service and the FBI and you name it I've
gone there and shown them what I do
a lot of my a lot of the people that I
used to work with who are out of the job
are in the wind you know and some of
these people are way more trained than I
am you know uh
it's interesting what it the the reason
why I get so get looked for and they ask
me questions is because I actually have
the experience that my University was
the most dangerous city on the planet
and when people ask me about some of
that stuff like I could speak from the
experience as far as encountering some
of that directly some of the people that
I used to work with who were way better
at it than I am
are in the wind yeah interesting thing
in Mexico if you are the police
organization and you get
fired or you quit you are ineligible to
join another police organization that
that discounts you so for somebody like
me who was a professional
operations group member or police
officer in Mexico of that region
there's no options for me outside of
that
so they they themselves basically have
created this
inescapable box for some of these people
that go into that line of work and what
do they go after you know
I've heard offers of twelve thousand
dollars to join uh some of the
organizations out there
plus you know they get benefits not like
the government you know I'm still
waiting for my liquidation my my
liquidation check this has been out of
it out of service for like six seven
years I'm still waiting for my check
uh so some of these people it's obvious
that the opportunities are presented to
them out there are stronger you know and
again the youth is
what gets eaten by this war and that's
one of the main things that they start
with just the youth we had a phenomenon
in Tijuana early early night late 90s
early 2000s called the Narco Juniors
Narco juniors are basically bored middle
middle fat middle uh middle class or
upper class families had kids that were
bored and they just joined some of these
cartel groups
uh these cartel groups saw in them
opportunities to get into regular
industry to go through the family of
businesses to kind of establish
themselves use
some of those businesses to store for
storage or figure out how to use some of
their transportation businesses for drug
muelling so this is how they start
in getting into different areas you know
that they regularly couldn't
and
you know that's how it starts you know
you owe somebody uh they get into paid
paid protection uh type schemes which
are also common all over Mexico
and uh sooner or later they start owning
businesses and they regulate some of
their income so they become part of the
uh part of the part of the local economy
in a big way
I had this experience and seeing a lot
where we're driving down this shitty
Street and all of a sudden it became a
cool nice you know little curvy High it
got like a highway type thing and I
looked around there it's like this is a
nice Road
and the guy was with me said yeah the
cartels built it you know
um you go to some of these towns and the
cartels are the government there they
build the hospitals they built the
churches they built the schools
cobit happens they're enforcing The Mask
mandates you know they're out enforcing
forcing the mass mandates the
stay-at-home policies
they're the ones uh delivering supplies
to the the townspeople and bags you know
courtesy of so-and-so cartel
you know so they they they become the
the Robin Hood characters of their
environments if they're smart you know
these groups basically turn into that
you know Robin Hood you know stealing
from the rich and giving to the poor or
at least that's the projection that they
give
what's the role of violence in this
operation I am extreme uh you know it
used to be that there were rules as you
say like
you know don't go after kids don't go
after women but all those things are
gone now you know they had been gone for
decades I think
uh the escalation of violence you know
you kill one of mine I'll kill four of
yours you kill four of mine I'll go
after your family because you were in
hiding
um there's stories of uh high-level
cartel people getting their you know
sons and and daughters you know murdered
mutilated uh and revenge killings so
I think it's uh it's at a point where it
spiraled a lot of semblance of a rule
set as far as who can get exposed to
some of this violence those highly
produced Isis videos
where they show torture and executions
uh According to some of the sources that
I've talked to here in the United States
that we're looking at that phenomenon
they said that it seems to be that that
was influenced by some of the Narco Blog
videos that that were coming out of
Mexico early in the early 2000s
basically that some of these groups were
the first ones that got wind of the fact
that you can
export Terror or the horror that an
execution has through social media
way back when Facebook was a bit more a
bit more of a Wildland area you could
see these in news feeds uh videos of
executions tortures and stuff like that
coming out of Mexico on Facebook way
back when wow this was a different time
um the people who criticize social media
and the moderation is a tough it's a
tough job because the brutal world out
there I mean I remember seeing some of
these Isis videos on on on Facebook way
back when and they you know they cracked
down all that but uh one that's kind of
clear and I'll see I'm not gonna say
where to find it but people out there
might have seen it because some of these
videos get shared through WhatsApp
groups and
chat groups out there uh one of the ones
that caught my attention way back when
was a guy getting two guys getting
executed by a chainsaw
um and
you know people can kind of
think imagine what that would be like
but uh this is produced on purpose like
this video it's a cartel group caught
two rival cartel members and a way to
send a message to those uh that rival
cartel is to basically execute these
people in front of a camera uh I mean
you can't get to your Rivals but you can
you can make them see what they're doing
or at least make their people look at
what happens if you you know invade
their territory
just an escalation of brutality in the
violence as well I mean and at least a
terror and then sort of mass
communication of Terror yeah I mean you
you have videos of some of these people
engaging in cannibalism in front of a
video to see how brutal they are or
uh people taking out somebody's heart
while they're alive you know and filming
it and you know it used to be social
media as a whole you'll see some of
these videos they would they would get
put down and and for in a few days
but now there's telegram groups uh
there's uh you know there's Live Leaks
there's a bunch of other uh sites out
there that kind of disperse some of this
these videos and
it's basically a bulletin board for them
as far as you know hey you got into my
territory well this is what's going to
happen to you
is there a game theoretic
way to uh remove this kind of brutality
to de-escalate the brutality because it
seems like if a cartel takes
power that exceeds the power of
politicians in a locality there's a
strong incentive to reduce the brutality
to uh to crack down on this kind of
Chainsaw executions you know uh there
was a recent leak of uh government files
come the guacamaya leaks it's our
version of WikiLeaks I guess and it was
uh mostly uh documents coming out of the
Mexican military
I haven't seen it talked about a lot
here in Stateside but it's a pretty big
thing down in Mexico
and in some of those documents it
revealed how
powerless the government is I mean as
far as the military goes so that's
another player in Mexico the military
the military has been out in the in
force in the streets basically doing a
policing role since Felipe Calderon was
the administration he basically
militarized the drug war
um Felipe Calderon was at the uh to the
right of the political spectrum and his
main rival who was his way to the left
is now in power
and one of the campaign promises he had
was to demilitarize the the drug war to
send the military back to its barracks
and all that and he's basically
continuing on they just passed the uh
some legislation that basically uh keeps
the military on the streets for a few
more three more years you know
um
and I think some of these documents that
were leaked uh are very telling as far
as why that is
uh they have the military now has a vast
amount of power when it comes to
security industry I mean they're in
charge of building airports and drain
lines in Mexico now
um their document themselves show how
certain regions uh in Mexico who have a
specific military uh presence work for
one side or favor one side of the cartel
they're corrupted too
so there's these military forces that
are in part corrupted yes and the cartel
which operates with violence somehow
finding a balance between each other no
it just feels like throughout human
history there's a
dictators or leaders that come
into situations like this and really
crack down on the violence yeah uh so it
seems like that's not happening it seems
like there's a kind of uh Market of
violence happening here there's a
systemic Amnesia that happens every
presidency in Mexico
so uh president comes in he has five to
six years to do whatever he needs to do
and he does everything and as soon as
he's gone
everything he did even even the what was
working gets chopped off police
organizations get uh defunct or change
or their names get changed uniforms
change so there's a lot of turnover uh
everywhere every five years federally
there's a turnover and then things
change what about the cartels do they
persist the leadership persists I mean
the scene of law cartel has a has had a
figurehead behind it since the 80s the
same one you know uh I mean it's a it's
a Federation of smaller cartels that are
all kind of linked up but the pretty
much historically who's considered the
head of the the senola cartel El Maya
sambada has been has been there since
you know since the 80s so in a way yeah
he he's persisting he's surviving all
these uh presidencies
again these documents that were leaked
are a clear sign of what strengths and
weaknesses there are as far as the the
government's main weapon against some of
these criminal Group which is the
military
and if people doubt this they can look
it up now online because all these
documents are out there
um but you know just a clear thing
the Mexican Navy or the marina doesn't
work with the Mexican army they don't
speak to each other so that should tell
you everything you need to know as far
as uh trust that could be just
bureaucratic dysfunction they don't
trust each other are they both
struggling with the problem of
corruption some of these documents that
are already that are already out there
talk about uh uh the ports in Mexico
which are probably the main conduit of
uh precursors of methamphetamines and
precursors of things like fentanyl into
the country they're operated and guarded
by the marina right so these things are
happening under their watch and then you
get uh talks of talk about the Army in
certain places basically working
uh counter cartel operations not too too
specifically one side not not another
you know as far as the Rival groups out
there
and we have a long history of some of
these uh groups going uh military groups
going rogue Los Santas are a prime
example of this these uh Special Forces
uh units that basically turned around
and went to work as bodyguards for the
golf cartel and then
decided but what they basically did was
an internship with a cartel you know
they went out there did bodyguarding for
the golf cartel
and then I realized it can do a better
job than they were doing so they started
their own
sparking off one of these again one of
the bloodiest kind of like uh internal
Cartel Wars in Mexico's history